[Musique]
excellent mardi 26 janvier à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue sur rt france info au
décryptage invités analyse c'est parti
pour deux heures d'émission tout de
suite les titres pas de décision ni
d'allocutions avant la fin de la semaine
sur un troisième confinement le mot
d'ordre à la veille d'un énième conseil
de défense sanitaire il faut d'abord
connaître les effets du couvre-feu
et ce alors que le président du conseil
scientifique plaide pour plus de
restrictions m6 je cite on n'est pas à
trois jours près côté vaccins si sanofi
n'est pas dans la course laboratoire
français va conditionner plus de 100
millions de doses de vaccins à pfizer
but intec d'ici la fin de l'année
[Musique]
j - 5 emmanuel macron a donné jusqu'à
lundi aux signataires aux signataires de
la charte de l'islam pour parapher un
texte salué par l'elysée comme je cite
un engagement net et précis en faveur de
la république
si cinq fédérations du cfcm l'ont signé
trois refusent toujours de l'approuver
une dernière à la soutient seulement
nouvelle journée de manifestations en
tunisie depuis la mi janvier le dixième
anniversaire de la révolution de jasmin
les rassemblements se succèdent dans
plusieurs villes pour réclamer une
meilleure politique sociale et la
libération de centaines de
protestataires interpellés par la police
[Musique]
adan on savait avant la fin de la
semaine d'un éventuel reconfirmant sur
la sémantique ce matin dany espagne et
runa chez la ministre délégué à
l'industrie mais finalement urgent
d'attendre un même si la pression du
monde médical montrent une communication
difficile qui exaspère élus et
déstabilise les français voient les deux
belles années au confinement ou pas
telle est la grande question
selon un dernier sondage opinionway plus
de 70% des français s'y prépare mais du
côté du gouvernement
l'idée n'est pas encore arrêtée à
l'image du président du conseil
scientifique métronome souvent des
prises des décisions de l'exécutif
nous avons deux possibilités on attend
la fin de la semaine pour disposer des
résultats de la deuxième enquête flash
de santé publique france et des deux
semaines de recul pour évaluer l'impact
du couvre-feu à 18 heures seconde
possibilité au vu des premières données
qui montrent que le variant anglais
circule de manière plus importante qu'on
ne le pense et on anticipe pour ma part
je pense qu'on n'est pas dans l'extrême
urgence
on n'est pas à une semaine près une
dernière déclaration en une d'un journal
qui pose problème
d'autant que quelques heures auparavant
le président du conseil scientifique
déclaré qu'il y avait urgence face à un
virus diabolique un changement de temps
en moins de 48 heures pour une ultime
mise au point je n'ai pas changé d'un
iota entre dimanche et aujourd'hui la
décision doit être prise entre la fin de
semaine et le milieu de la semaine
prochaine
on n'est pas à trois jours près ce n'est
pas de l'extrême urgence comme une
opération chirurgicale
cette décision est extrêmement lourde il
faut tout peser une prise de décision
tardive du gouvernement qui agace
l'opposition qui réclame plus de
discussions
ce que nous demandons depuis le début
c'est que ce soit les politiques qui
prennent des décisions et non pas un
conseil scientifique qui est seulement
là pour donner un avis leur confinement
serait un échec
le président de la république décide
vous qui êtes journaliste moi qui suis
député on ne sait rien de ce qui va être
annoncé mercredi
on est suspendu à notre poste de
télévision comme tous les citoyens quel
est le lieu des changes de débats au
car en confinement total aurait des
conséquences humaines très fortes
notamment chez les jeunes de plus en
plus en difficulté
la résilience des français est
formidable par ailleurs en cas de retour
à 1 re confinement strict la question se
posera d'un vote du parlement pour
l'autoriser ou non cacophonie au sein du
parlement mais aussi dans certaines
mairies comme à cabourg sans mère
tristan duval a informé lundi en
ouverture du conseil municipal qu'un roc
ont finement de cinq semaines allaient
être annoncées dès ce mercredi
information démentie sur les réseaux
sociaux par le préfet du calvados
tristan duval a présenté lui ses excuses
sur twitter précisant qu'il ne s'agit
que de rumeurs en cours tergiversations
ou pas ces dernières heures la ministre
chargé de l'industrie a confirmé qu' à
sa connaissance et à ce stade il n'y
avait pas raison de décider d'un
confinement une crise sanitaire
difficile à gérer qui émet donc à rude
épreuve les français plus que jamais
dans l'incertitude on en parle avec
alexis poulain c'est l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france emmanuel
macron avait prévenu lors de la dernière
campagne présidentielle je cite c'est
moi ou le chaos
à un an de la fin de son mandat la
situation ressemble de plus en plus haut
au chaos du moins en matière de
communication gouvernementale oui alors
c'est vrai que cette promesse à moi ou
le chaos n'est pas devenue une prophétie
et on a vraiment l'impression que c'est
le chaos
on compte en tout cas en ce qui concerne
la communication du gouvernement
on a eu une annonce selon le jdd
dimanche quai de l'emac où on allait
parler cette semaine pour annoncer de
grandes choses et puis non démentie il
ne parlera pas cette semaine donc on est
suspendu aux lèvres du président que
va-t-il dire mes côtés de jean castex du
premier ministre c'est pas mieux
il annonce aux députés qu'il y aura un
conseil de défense de pain qu'il met la
santé avant toute chose qui le prend
aussi en compte les impacts qui existent
de ces stratégies erratique sur la santé
psychologique sur l'économie également
tout ça est dans le tuyau on a
l'impression que finalement les 66
millions de procureur commence à peser
sur les décisions de l'exécutif qui
redescend de l'olympe
mais aussi le choix des personnels
scientifiques puisque côté conseil
scientifique c'est aussi un pédalage un
rétropédalage du professeur delfraissy
comme vous venez de le dire
dimanche il se veut extrêmement
alarmiste parlant de ce virus diabolique
et puis finalement il se dit qu'on peut
attendre trois jours ou une semaine
il n'y a pas d'urgence donc tout ça est
vraiment dans un degré d'impréparation
et de chaos communicationnel assez
terrible et puis rappelons les chiffres
on en est à 26000 contamination hier
plus de 3000 hospitalisation le curseur
qui avait été mis par le président de la
république en décembre c'était 5000 cas
par jour pour des cons finis donc on en
est vraiment loin aujourd'hui
alors on parle de la communication
gouvernementale mais est ce qu'on peut
parler aussi de carreaux en matière de
stratégie sanitaire
alors oui là aussi on ne comprend plus
rien le ministre de la santé qui est un
des trois rares ministres autorisé à
prendre la parole en public annoncèrent
olivier ferrand 1
le matin devant le cénacle objectif
était de vacciner 15 millions de
personnes avant l'été personnes avec des
faiblesses des comorbidités d'aidés
publiques à risque et puis le soir sur
le plateau d'un jt il annonçait 70
millions de français vaccinés après
l'été très rapidement sachant qu'on est
que 67 millions de français donc tout le
monde se pose la question mais d'où il
sort ses trois millions de français
supplémentaires
il n'a jamais répondu et puis côté
vaccins alors là c'est quand même
incroyable
aujourd'hui on a décidé que non on
allongerait pas la durée d'injection
entre la première piqûre et la deuxième
piqûre et qu'on s'en tiendraient aux
recommandations des nabots tant mieux
mais la question se pose parce qu'on est
toujours dense et ce risque de ne pas
avoir suffisamment de doses
puisque les vaccins qui est les
candidats vaccins qui avait été commandé
notamment sanofi vaccin français ou
pasteur pasteur a jeté l'épongé sur le
vaccin il va se concentrer sur d'autres
solutions et c'est un peu partout pareil
on apprend que sanofi lui produira des
doses plus tard pour pouvoir produire du
vaccin de pfizer
mais on reste toujours là on encore dans
le l'impréparation et le site à savoir
est-ce qu'on va recevoir suffisamment de
doses est-ce que les vaccins vont
fonctionner avec tous ces variants là
encore on navigue à vue et ce n'est pas
très rassurant
alors bruno le maire lui dit eh bien il
faut faire confiance au génie français à
la start up nation et il appelle les
entreprises françaises des
biotechnologies à être audacieuse à
prendre des risques et à créer de
nouveaux protocoles aussi pourquoi pas
trouver des nouveaux médicaments
c'est quand même assez spécial sachant
qu'il existe un déjà des médicaments là
la colle show qui nous parle de cole
corona il y avait là que rocky monde
essaye des choses des deux protocoles ya
autre chose que les vaccins il va
falloir peut-être se résoudre à trouver
autrement
alex est pour l'heure vous venez de
parler alain stands
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
justement matière économique
à quoi faut-il s'attendre est ce qu'il
faut craindre des choses alors oui
beaucoup à craindre parce que je le
crois qu'il en coûte devient ça va
coûter vraiment trop cher il ya des
notes qui commencent à fuiter de bercy
disant que trois mois de plus et on ne
pourra pas tenir le soutien qu'on fait
aux entreprises qu'on demande à auxquels
on demande de fermer il faut se rappeler
les déclarations de bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui sur l'antenne
d'une radio nationale
parler de 6% de croissance en disant
vous inquiétez pas y aura un rebond en
2021 ça c'était à la fin de la dernière
puis en début d'année il revient à la
radio pour dire écoutez on garde les 6%
mais ce sera un défi
et puis la plus récemment il dit bon 6%
alors là ça va être très difficile
surtout si on re confine le medef qui
dit car confinement sera intenable
les entreprises aussi qu'ils commencent
à témoigner de leur difficulté à la fois
d'avoir des aides et de tenir on parle
d'une pme sur deux qui pourraient mettre
la clé sous la porte si on continue ses
stratégies sanitaires qui demande à tous
de fermer le fmi le fonds monétaire
international qui par son bureau
parisien est en train d'avancer des
pions pour dire qu'il va peut-être
falloir que la france fasse des réformes
commencent à s'intéresser à sa tête
corona parce qu'elle va être intenable
et que on se retrouverait sans doute en
france avec un scénario à la grecque
vous avez vu ce qui est arrivé en grèce
lors de la crise de 2008 eh bien
peut-être qu'avec cette crise sanitaire
du corona la france deviendrait la
nouvelle grèce en 2021 2022
donc ça devient intenable cette phrase
de moi ou le chaos elle est totalement
anachronique maintenant on voit que
quatre ans dans le mandat des malades
macron c'est le chaos total
et je ne vois pas quel bilan il va
pouvoir défendre en 2022
s'il souhaite se représenter ça va être
extrêmement difficile et il faudra
changer de ritournelles entre moi et le
chaos parce que lors des derniers
sondages on a vu que pour un premier
tour potentiellement marine le pen
serait devant emmanuel macron lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 1 2
merci alexis poulain
d'avoir répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes
emmanuel macron qui en tout cas tire les
leçons de la crise sanitaire appel aux
bilans tout à l'heure du président
français au forum économique mondial qui
se tient dans la très chic station de
ski de davos en suisse selon lui la
pandémie a permis de mettre au centre
l'humain plutôt que l'économie à
outrance je crois qu'on a quelques
leçons à retenir de ce qu'on vit tous
ensemble depuis un peu plus d'un an et
qui va encore durer on le sait pendant
des mois
certains nous disent des années avec en
tout cas une présence plus ou moins
forte de ce virus
je crois que la première chose que ça
nous a renseignés c'est qu'on ne peut
pas penser l'économie sans l'humain
alors ça paraît être une banalité de
dire ça enfin nous avons fait dans tous
nos pays quelque chose qui était
considéré comme impensable c'est à dire
qu'on a arrêté toutes les activités
économiques pour protéger des vies
première leçon et on s'est rappelé que
l'économie dont vous parlez c'était une
science morale et donc la vie des hommes
primer sur les échanges et les chiffres
la deuxième chose c'est que cette
période nous rappelle notre
vulnérabilité à titre personnel si je
puis dire j'en ai fait les frais en
attrapant mais comme organisation
entreprise société pays et la
vulnérabilité ça veut dire qu'on ne peut
pas penser nos organisations notre
économie sans l'intégrer et c'était au
fond une idée qui nous paraissaient
certains avaient plus conscience que
d'autres sur ce sujet mais qui nous
paraissait parfois lointaine quand on
parlait de l'écologie et du climat
mais c'est la même notion c'est de dire
ce qui se passe autour de nous a un
impact sur notre quotidien et peut en
quelque sorte briser les chaînes changé
nos vies
une fois que j'ai dit ça ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut rien reconstruire à mes
yeux dans le monde d'après qu'ovide qui
ne tirent les leçons de ces deux
éléments fondamentaux à la pandémie qui
impacte le pib mondial de 22 mille
liards de dollars entre 2020 et 2025
selon les estimations aujourd'hui du
fonds monétaire internationale impactée
également les entreprises françaises qui
craignent un éventuel troisième
confinement le rappel conseil de défense
demain à l'elysée une pme sur deux se
déclare inquiète pour son avenir alors
que 49% des chefs d'entreprise estiment
ne pas être en capacité de supporter une
troisième mise sous cloche selon une
étude de la confédération des petites et
moyennes entreprises pour 2021 les
perspectives sont mitigées mais pas
catastrophique
si 52 % des répondants prévoient une
baisse de chiffre d'affaires dans les
prochains mois
48 % anticipent un maintien ou même une
hausse de même 6 25 % envisagent de
réduire leurs effectifs 66% pensent le
maintenir et 9 % prévoient de recruter
et alors que l'exécutif tergiverse sur
un éventuel troisième confinement quel
impact celui ci aurait t'il sur
l'économie place tout de suite au
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et nos invités question saint-etienne
économiste et jean guilhem darré délégué
général du syndicat des indépendants
étaient tpe les très petites entreprises
bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france une pme sur
deux craint donc je le disais de ne pas
pouvoir supporter un troisième confinant
alexis blanc l'a rappelé également tout
à l'heure c'est une étude
une enquête de la ceppm la confédération
des petites et moyennes entreprises qui
a interrogé 2400 dirigeante
regardez sur ces chiffres dont 49 pour
cent des chefs d'entreprise estiment ne
pas être en capacité de supporter un
troisième confinement 33% des chefs
d'entreprise ont le sentiment que leur
entreprise est sous perfusion de l'état
ces chiffres messieurs ils font froid
dans le dos la mise en place d'un
troisième confinement ce serait quoi ce
serait un coup de grâce à jean guilhem
darré
nous nous avons réalisé une enquête nous
mêmes à auprès des nouveaux prêts des
pme auprès des tpe des artisans des
commerçants des entreprises de moins de
dix salariés
les chiffres sont en ligne on constate
effectivement que 71 % de ces
entreprises ont connu une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires sur l'année 2020 et
que pour 51% à ce jour elle rencontre
des difficultés de trésorerie soit
importante soit jusqu'à catastrophique
alors forcément dans ce contexte là avec
en plus un confinement qui pourrait
arriver dans les prochains jours la
situation pourrait pour un grand nombre
d'entre elles a mené à une impossibilité
de rebond on a clairement pour celles
qui on l'utilisé qui ont utilisé le pg e
on en a à peu près 40% qu'ils ont déjà
consommé quasiment dans son intégralité
et surtout dans la très grande majorité
des gars 90% des cas c'était pour payer
des charges les charges courantes et
et les tpe donc les très petites
entreprises elles représentent 95% des
entreprises françaises qu'est ce que ça
signifie qu'elles jouent leur survie de
cette manière là avec cette crise du coc
vie de christian saint-etienne alors
c'est 95 % en nombre b en chiffres
d'affaires ont valeur ajoutée surtout
c'est un de l'ordre du tiers mais pense
qu'on entend par dix ans les pme de
moins de 50 personnes
donc c'était effectivement décisif pour
l'emploi sur les territoires c'est
décisif pour l'emploi dans le dans le
commerce
ce que l'on observe c'est que comme les
chiffres qui viennent d'être donnés le
confirme l'année 2020 a vu une baisse de
l'activité de 9% mais c'est pas 9% pour
tout le monde
vous avez entre 15 et 20 % de l'économie
en équivalent pipe qui a augmenté son
activité et qui va accélérer en 2021
vous avez 60 65 % qui a baissé de 9%
comme l'économie et vous avez 15 % qui
va être totalement restructurée on
estime qu'il va falloir former et
reformer un million et demi de personnes
sur 18 mois 2 ans on ne voit pas l'état
se prépare et d'ailleurs à cet effort là
donc dans ce contexte d'extrême
fragilité où on estime qu'il y a au
niveau de l'économie française 12 ou 13%
ce qu'on appelle les entreprises zombies
c'est à dire les entreprises qui n'ont
n'ont même pas le profit nécessaires
pour payer les intérêts sur leur
endettement
donc dans ce contexte d'extrême
fragilité rajouter un nouveau
confinement
tout dépend de la nature du confinement
d'ailleurs rajouté un nouveau
confinement disons strictes comme celui
du printemps 2020 serait se réparer
catastrophe d'autant plus que
sur ce qui reste encore avec la tête au
dessus du niveau de la mer c'est ce sont
les entreprises qui sont défendues et
soutenue par la dette publique mais sais
tu dors les autres les autres comment
comment elles peuvent faire genre
jean-guilhem darré a
pour se relever comment faire et puis
combien vont rester sur le carreau
également alors nous on a évalué à
environ 300 milles le nombre de tpe qui
pourrait disparaître d'ici la fin de
l'année soit qu'elles n'auront pas la
possibilité de rembourser leurs pge soi
que je ne rompt pas la possibilité de
payer leurs dettes parce que tout
naturellement n'ont pas eu d'impact tenu
le pg il n'y a pas 36 façons en fait de
se remettre soit l'activité reprend mais
bon a priori on n'est pas parti pour sur
les prochains mois
le président de la république d'ailleurs
elle a indiqué tout à l'heure donc la
seule solution finalement c'est
s'étendit âgées une une annulation
clairement l'annulation des charges que
ce soit les charges sociales les charges
fiscales et pourquoi pas aussi une
annulation pour les entreprises qui ont
la possibilité de rebondir
une animation du pge alors certes ça va
entre guillemets coûter de l'argent on
en est bien conscient maintenant ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que si on regarde
au niveau européen la france a encore
des marges de manoeuvre par rapport à
nos voisins allemands ou à nos voisins
anglais compte tenu du fait que le
niveau des aides qui a été qu'ils ont
été accordés jusqu'à présent et je parle
naturellement des tpe est nettement
moins en france on a en a mis sur la
table 25 milliards d'euros en allemagne
c'était 81 milliards en angleterre
c'était c'était 50 milliards donc il ya
quand même des possibilités qui existent
à pays comparables eric ne me comparable
de soutenir encore nos entreprises
celles au minimum qui qui ont la
possibilité de rebondir mais pas dans
les conditions dans lesquelles on est
avec un mur de dette insurmontable
je n'ai qu'à le gouvernement compte
tenir sa stratégie du quoi qu'il en
coûte je vous propose de voir ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure
elisabeth bornes la ministre du travail
tant que la crise le rendra nécessaire
on protégera les emplois avec l'activité
partielle temps qu'il faudra aussi
longtemps que nécessaire
la priorité est de sauver le maximum
d'emplois il n'y a aucun doute le quoi
qu'il en coûte durera aussi longtemps
que la crise le nécessitera donc quoi
qu'il en coûte donc avec le chômage
partiel ça sauf les emplois mais est-ce
que c'est pas plutôt une mission
cloches qui empêche les entreprises de
déposer le bilan est ce que c'est pas au
final reculer pour mieux sauter et
christian saint-etienne il ya un tiers
des entreprises qui sont en difficulté
qui de toute façon vont disparaître
parce qu'elle était déjà pour la plupart
en difficulté avant le confinement toute
la question c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est de reformer les
travailleurs pour qu'on puisse les
déplacer vers les activités qui vont
redémarrer à partir du mois de mai juin
faut pas non plus désespérée on a encore
trois mois difficiles mais il ya quand
même une corrélation très forte entre le
froid et l'humidité et d'une part et la
pandémie donc à partir de d'avril il va
y avoir une très forte amélioration par
ailleurs on a une vaccination qui
produira des effets d'ici avril sur les
pets personnes faibles donc on va se
retrouver avec une situation où à partir
de mai juin on va avoir un certain
rebond alors vous avez raison comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure on va aider les
entreprises vraisemblablement jusqu'au
milieu de l'année à travers le chômage
partiel mais à partir de la deuxième
moitié de l'année ce qu'il va falloir
faire c'est faire le tri entre les
entreprises qui peuvent survivre
celle là effectivement il n'y aura pas
d'annulations d'être personne peut
annuler la dette parce que s'il ya une
contrepartie est la contrepartie c'est
quelqu'un qui paye ça sera toujours le
contribuable donc c'est une autre
nouvelle augmentation de de
l'endettement public ce qui aura
probablement est-ce que le gouvernement
compte qu'ils commencent à essayer de
faire n'est qu'il ne fait pas avec
lenteur nécessaire
c'est d aide en fonds propres le
gouvernement travaille sur des aides en
quasi fonds propres il est en
négociation avec la commission
européenne à hauteur de 20 milliards
d'euros mais c'est très insuffisant et
va falloir compléter cette initiative de
quasi fonds propres par une initiative
de fonds propres de l'ordre de 70
milliards d'euros j'ai publié des
propositions il ya certains groupes qui
réfléchissent sur cette initiative là et
ça sera pas pour aider les entreprises
et qui vont mal ça sera pour aider les
entreprises qui sont encore viable
c'est-à-dire les entreprises qui
n'étaient pas en perte à voir la
pandémie et qui avait encore des fonds
propres
positif à la fin 2020 donc il va y avoir
l'année 2021 va être une année de très
forte restructuration de l'appareil de
production donc ça va être une année
désagréable et difficile
tout le monde ne sera pas aider et
sauver mais il faut faire en sorte que
le potentiel de redéveloppement et de
redéploiement de l'économie française
soit reconstruit pour que on est des
années correct en 22 et 23 par les
années 2022 2023 je propose un petit
flashback en 2010 est parce qu un
chiffre qui inquiète les économistes
dont vous faites partie celui de la
dette
98 5% du produit intérieur brut en 2010
est au moment de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron plus de 122 % cette année à cause
des mesures prises pour relancer
l'économie à la suite donc de la crise
du duc hobbit qui va payer à jean
guilhem darré
pour l'instant on a la possibilité
encore d'emprunter la france emprunte à
des taux extrêmement intéressant bono le
maire a indiqué qu'il pourrait y avoir
des possibilités de cantonner la dette
qu'ovide donc dans l'absolu on n'est pas
très inquiet sur l'avenir
nous ce qui nous inquiète ce sont nos
entreprises
et c'est assez symptomatique d'ailleurs
ce que vous indiquiez par rapport à
madame bornes on parle de soutien aux
salariés quand on parle de soutien de
l'emploi on parle de soutien aux
salariés mais pour qu'il y ait des
salariés pour qu'il y ait de l'emploi il
faut qu'ils aient des entreprises sinon
on va pas s'en sortir
les fonds propres et quasi fonds propres
tout ça c'est intéressant ce sont les
éléments qui peuvent être mis sur la
table mais ça va ça va durer pendant 7
ans pendant 10 ans et ça reste quand
même une somme qui va être à rembourser
donc il faut bien concevoir que dans
l'esprit du chef d'entreprise bossé
pendant 7 ans pendant 10 ans pour
rembourser une dette dont il n'est pas
responsable en aucune en aucune façon et
qui lui aura servi à payer des charges
courantes c'est totalement abérrant donc
la possibilité on n'est pas les seuls à
le dire certains économistes le disent
aussi
la possibilité d'annuler les dettes
totalement partiellement on peut voir
effectivement selon l'état de la
structure est une possibilité à
envisager très sérieusement
dernière question le mot de la fin
christian saint-etienne le medef qui a
appelé à maintenir les commerces ouverts
en cas de reconfigurer puis le médecin
et je re martyrs de l'union française
pour une médecine lim qui propose lui
d'ouvrir les petits commerces et de
fermer les grandes surfaces cette
fois-ci bonne idée je parle évidemment à
l'économiste un que vous êtes non il
faut laisser l'ensemble des commerces et
des artisans ou r c'est pas eux qui sont
à l'origine de la dissémination du coc
vide
il faut regarder on le sait ça fait ça
fait plus de six mois qu'on le sait
c'est dans la sphère privée que le coc
vide circule le plus et surtout dans les
fêtes privées conte dont on a eu
connaissance dans les derniers mois
donc c'est pas en accusant le commerce
et les artisans qu'on progresse
l'économiste encore vivant si on ferme
l'économie tout meurt donc ça a été la
grande erreur au printemps de fermer
beaucoup plus longtemps que les
autrichiens les allemands nous avons
réouvert au 11 mai ils ont réouvert
quinze jours plus tôt il faut savoir que
une semaine complète de fermeture ça
coûte 0,8 à 0,9 point depuis une
vingtaine de milliards par semaine donc
fermé c'est une stupidité absolue ce qui
est en revanche nécessaire c'est de
fermer les frontières éventuellement de
limiter les transports de région à
région
donc plutôt que de fermer mais ces
mesures de bon sens le gouvernement n'a
pas voulu les mettre en oeuvre pour des
raisons idéologiques
il y vient tardivement en exigent
maintenant mais seulement maintenant
alors que ça fait quasiment un an qu'on
est dans cette pandémie des tests pcr
pour les gens qui viennent des autres
pays européens
et quand vous regardez je termine par là
les pays qui s'en sont bien sortis comme
taïwan et la corée du sud
ils ont totalement fermé leurs
frontières et très vite c'est comme ça
qu'ils s'en sont sortis donc bouclé les
français en laissant les frontières
ouvertes c'est une aberration absolue
donc il faut fermer les frontières sont
contrôler les mouvements de population à
l'intérieur du territoire
peut-être en limitant les transferts de
région à région
mais fermer les commerces et les
artisans en laissant les frontières
ouvertes c'est une aberration absolue
merci christian saint-etienne d'avoir
répondu à la question je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste merci également à
vous jean guilhem darré d'avoir
également répondu à nos questions et
vous êtes le délégué général du syndicat
indépendant des des tpe
restez avec nous sur arte france dans un
instant la charte de l'islam 6,5
fédération sur les neuf qui la composent
qui composent le conseil français du
culte musulman l'ont déjà signé trois ne
reconnaissent toujours pas ce texte
et puis gros plans également sur la
tunisie où les manifestations continuent
pour de meilleures conditions sociales
alors qu'il ya un remaniement
ministériel a lieu là tout de suite
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire les rites
des idées courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême musée
de la société tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo l'eau
ou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et semis et c'est un peu le passage de
relais d'al qaïda l'état islamique
quelque part dans notre politique
internationale bien évident qu'il faut
pas créer les conditions à nouveau une
terre jihad et de cet appel d'air
justement au recrutement l'a
malheureusement fait en syrie en irak
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé
donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
au loin de paris mais toujours loin de
ce qu'il est guéri majoritaire mâcon et
passe un tour de tracteur avec nous
couvrons campagne il faut savoir c'est
qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas forêts et aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue sur arte france si vous nous
rejoignez il est 20h30 heure française
la charte de l'islam emmanuel macron a
donné jusqu'à lundi aux signataires pour
l'approuver
cinq des neuf fédérations du conseil
français du culte musulman l'ont signée
ski emmanuel macron salue comme je cite
à un engagement net et précis on va en
faveur de la république problème le
texte n'est toujours pas ratifiée par
trois fédérations qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ce texte une
autre soutien documents sans pour autant
l'avoir paraphé explications en images
[Musique]
alors que le 18 janvier dernier le
président de la république avait donné
aux signataires quinze jours pour
apposer leur signature sur ce document
ou est-ce qu'on emmenait quelques jours
à quelques jours de l'ultimatum donné
par emmanuel macron on en parle avec
mohammed moussaoui le président du cfcm
le conseil français du culte musulman
bonsoir mohammed moussaoui merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
les trois fédérations musulmanes déplore
l'absence de consensus celles qui n'ont
pas signé un ce texte déplore un manque
de consensus autour de ce texte qui je
cite est de nature à fragiliser les
liens entre les liens de confiance entre
les musulmans de france est la nation
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
l'islam de france c'est impossible islam
de france
il ne peut pas être laïque coûté
français se construit depuis des années
avec la création de ces institutions de
ces mosquées de ces discussions au
niveau local et au niveau national cette
étape celle de la charte et la création
du conseil national des imams fait
partie de ces de cette construction qui
s'inscrit dans le temps l'impossibilité
de construire cet islam de france n'est
pas tout à fait je pense le terme à m à
cette difficulté que nous rencontrons à
ces derniers jours en effet le texte de
la charte donc vous avez que ça vaut que
vous avez évoquées a été validé à 90
voire 4 95% de son contenu à l'unanimité
compris les trois fédérations qui n'ont
pas signé
il reste 5 à 10% qui portent surtout sur
des formulations et et des nuances de
certains articles et non pas sur les
grands principes qui ont été inscrits
dans cette charte
de ce point de vue je peux dire c'est
une avancée significative importante
il reste que les trois fédérations ont
demandé un temps de réflexion pour voir
s'ils peuvent paraphé également le texte
je dois dire et de réflexion de l'est de
combien de temps parce qu'on l'a dit il
ya un ultimatum
qui avait été lancée par l'elysée donc
c'est d'ici ce week-end d'ici lundi
comment convaincre ses fédérations
réticente sur quoi vont porter les
négociations comment réussir à tous se
mettre d'accord d'ici lundi
je ne pense pas qu'ils soient qui
viennent qui m'attend quelconque à
l'égard de cette fédération à l'égard du
conseil français du culte musulman je
pense que le dialogue que nous
poursuivons avec le président de la
république que nous remercions
d'ailleurs pour l'intérêt qu'il porte à
ce dossier important je pense que depuis
son discours à mulhouse bio le mur haut
et puis les rencontres qu'il a eues avec
le plaisir à bhl avec le conseil
français du culte musulman
il montre bien qu'il a à l'intérêt très
particulier à ce dossier
il souhaite que le culte musulman soit
organisée qui soit à la hauteur des
défis qu'ils rencontrent
maintenant je pense que les trois
fédérations comme je le disais avait
déjà validé le 17 janvier je dois le
préciser
ils ont accepté que la proposition qui a
été présenté aux prises en public soit
une proposition de consensus
il reste que les sectes 10% sur lesquels
ils ne peuvent pas mettre leur paraphe
mais à cette a7 je dirais 7e à cette
difficulté
j'ai toujours dit que huit fédérations
lorsqu'ils vont écrire un texte qui est
une coproduction forcément l'unanimité à
100 % sur chaque phrase
et [ __ ] possible et je pense que l'on
comprend mieux que nous avons tous les
est un très bon compromis
mais le fait qu'il manque ces signatures
à ce que vous le regrettez est ce que ça
veut dire que le cfcm appareil à diviser
je le regrette évidemment que les trois
fédérations n'est pas signé le lundi
dernier
mais il reste on encore le temps pour
qu'il le fasse de tomber je dois
rappeler que le plus important pour nous
c'est les documents fondateurs de
conseil national 10e
celui là il a été ratifié par les huit
fédérations à l'unanimité déjà du pilot
le 10 novembre dernier
donc nous avons déjà réalisé une
contrepartie du travail qui devant nous
et je pense que la mise en place du
conseil national estime axa devrait être
notre objectif premier
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
sur
division est ce qu'il ya une division au
sein du cfcm parce que les signatures ne
sont pas toutes présentes et est ce que
ces divisions si elles existent peuvent
mettre à mal le fragile édifice du
fameux islam de france voulue par
emmanuel macron suivre et je fais la
différence entre le fait de ne pas
parapher un texte et avoir discuté et à
accepter 90 à 95 au sort de ce texte
nous sommes là devant une difficulté
effectivement joue la corde mais il
n'est pas de nature à mettre en cause la
cohésion au sein du conseil ainsi du
culte musulman ça toujours été notre on
a eu des épisodes de cette nature dont
le passé il ya quelques jours et encore
la grande mosquée de paris le 28
décembre avait dit qu'elle ne ne
poursuivraient pas les travaux sur la
charte est sûre le conseil nation
indivisible
elle avait même dit que c'était
irrévocable et pourtant aujourd'hui elle
est autour de la table parmi les
principaux points de litige on peut
revenir là dessus à la définition des
ingérences étrangères et la définition
précise de l'islam politique
quand on regarde la composition du cfcm
le conseil français du culte musulman
que vous présidez on note la présence
d'une fédération turque qui refusent
d'ailleurs de signer la charte
si c'est le statu quo d'ici la semaine
prochaine même si vous avez dit il n'y a
pas de a pas d'ultimatum
emmanuel m'apprend avait quand même
donné une quinzaine de jours il ya dix
jours
si c'est toujours un statut secoue le
statu quo est ce qu'on pourra dire que
le cfcm n est pas représentatif
totalement des musulmans de france
le conseil français de culture is an
mais ne le conseille pas dans le nez
n'est pas représentatif des musulmans de
france ils représentatifs du culte
musulman c'est l'interlocuteur des
pouvoirs publics sur les question
cultuelles ne prétendons pas représenter
les musulmans en tant que citoyens ils
ont leurs représentants de la nation
mais je pense que le fait qu'il y ait
une fédération qui souhaiteraient rester
à l'extérieur on aussi en passe à chat
mais acceptant de travailler avec le
conseil français de culte musulman sur
la mise en place du conseil national du
mal à accepter que ce conseil national
10e puis sa grille et saisit mal et je
pense que ça peut être un une situation
de d'intermédiaire le temps que la
fédération regarde avec ses instances et
décidé une fine et de signer le document
je rappelle également que ce document il
va être soumis à toutes nos instances
régionales ce qu'on appelle le conseil
régional du culte musulman à nos
mosquées et les imams et les retours qui
seront faits par ces agriculteurs locaux
et permettront de d'améliorer le texte
de la charte donc le chat n'est pas
lui-même figé dans le temps il sera
amélioré par les retours et les retours
d'expérience que nous avons recueillies
auprès de nos acteurs locaux et je pense
que de ce point de vue une fédération
qui resterait peut-être qu'il mettrait
des amendements en attendant que tous
ces retours soient soient recueillies
peut être une solution également merci
mohammed moussaoui d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du conseil français du culte
musulman au liban manifestations ces
dernières heures contre les mesures
sanitaires pour tenter de lutter contre
le comité 19 avec des affrontements
entre forces de l'ordre et
protestataires qui ont fait une
trentaine de blessés
les autorités ont prolongé le
confinement jusqu'au 8 février pour
tenter d'endiguer la progression du
coran des virus et à la crise m
s'ajoute une crise économique qui n'en
finit pas mathilde romagnan
tripoli dans la brume des gaz
lacrymogènes forces de l'ordre et
manifestants se sont affrontés pendant
plusieurs heures ce lundi des centaines
de personnes ont défilé dans les rues et
lancé des pierres sur le siège des
autorités locales dans la deuxième ville
du pays selon la croix rouge libanaise
une trentaine de personnes ont été
blessées les manifestants protestent
contre le prolongement du confinement
dans le pays et la fermeture de tous les
commerces
jusqu'au 8 février une décision prise
par les autorités pour soulager les
hôpitaux saturés mais qui aggrave encore
la crise économique au pays du cèdre
nous allons mourir nous allons mourir
depuis quatorze quinze jours nous sommes
enfermés à la maison nous n'avons plus
d'argent ce n'est pas dans nos habitudes
vous voyez tout ce qui se passe tout
cela est à cause des dirigeants tout
état cause de vous nabih berry et michel
aoun cacher derrière vos posts vous
aimez vos posts et vous vous tenez avec
l'armée en face de nous jusqu'à ce que
vous nous pousser à bout et nous ne
pouvons pas nous battre avec l'armée
c'est impossible l'armée à notre armée
tout est de votre faute c'est tout ce
que je veux dire les gens ont faim les
gens n'ont pas de pain chez eux pas de
gaz pas d'essence nous n'avons plus rien
les gens sont au plus bas
l'état libanais ne se soucie pas de ses
habitants et les néglige ils sont dans
leur palais pour eux ça ne fait aucune
différence mais nous à tripoli avant fin
face à la situation sanitaire et
économique que traverse le pays la
banque mondiale a annoncé le financement
de la distribution de vaccins d'ici le
mois prochain une première pour
l'institution
une enveloppe de 34 millions de dollars
sera débloqué pour fournir des vaccins à
environ 2 millions de personnes à
manifestations en tunisie alors que le
remaniement ministériel est soumis ce
soir à un vote de confiance au parlement
et rassemblements se succèdent depuis la
mi janvier le dixième anniversaire de la
révolution de jasmin en cause les crises
qui sont multiples social économique
politique sanitaire que de précision
avec notre envoyé spécial à tunis issam
chebbi
[Applaudissements]
abbas m
une journée est sous tension aujourd'hui
avec un vote au parlement où est-ce
qu'on en est exactement effectivement
toujours au parlement et c'est depuis le
début de l'après midi à un pote qui doit
être soumis ce sera plus tôt au tard
dans la nuit et selon les dires de
certains et députés mais déjà de vives
tensions au sein même du parlement avec
une majorité de nos positions ok monter
au créneau et qu'il critique et bien sûr
l'organisation de ce gouvernement et
aime critiquer ouvertement la politique
du ministre qui premier ministre mais
chichis et a déclaré que son choix de
nouveaux ministres étaient pas du tout
ce qu'il fallait à la tunisie
actuellement le président de la
république taille s'arrêtent a même émis
son avis selon cette nouvelle domination
de certains ministres qui vont composer
et vont venir rejoindre le gouvernement
actuel du ministre mais chichis il a
déclaré que certains étaient vus comme
des ministres corrompus il a déclaré
également qu'il n'y avait pas assez de
femmes dans cette nouvelle composition
ministériel de nombreuses critiques
envers ce premier ministre car il faut
savoir être qu'une première avant
tunisie et des pics très très longtemps
le premier ministre est à la fois le
ministre de l'intérieur car il n'y a pas
de mr intérieur de pitch avec quelques
mois et c'est prévu avec cette nouvelle
nomination de certains ministres un
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
en attendant le premier ministre exerce
aussi le rôle ministre de l'intérieur
juillet reprochés selon dans l'est
surtout dans la gestion de ces
différentes tensions vous connais depuis
mi-janvier les tensions qui ont éclaté à
notamment avec le confinement mais qui
viennent s'ajouter à une crise
économique et sociale que la tunisie vit
maintenant depuis plus de dix ans
certains députés ont même déclaré qu'ils
pouvaient même être amené dans les jours
à venir la rejoindre les manifestants
dans la rue pour dénoncer la gestion de
ce gouvernement qui répondent pas
favorablement aux revendications des
tunisiens depuis maintenant plus de dix
ans mais de parler de tensions sociales
donc des tensions politiques qui
s'ajoute à un grand malaise social est
ce qu'il ya des nouvelles mobilisations
qui sont à prévoir prochainement le
territorie et les mobilisations elles
sont quotidiennes et ce depuis le 14
janvier détention d'éclater dans
certains quartiers populaires de la
capitale et puis il ya eu également un
effet boule de neige sur l'ensemble du
territoire de vives tensions dans des
villes la principale et des métropoles
de la tunisie des tensions entre jeunes
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
notamment des forces de l'ordre qui
n'ont pas hésité à miser de bombes
lacrymogènes pour disperser les
populations on a compté plus de 700
arrestations beaucoup de jeunes entre 14
et 25 ans dont la plupart way ont dû
comparaître devant la justice même si le
présent la république et le premier
ministre
bien sûr on fait une allocation pour
essayer de calmer un petit peu les
tensions que connaît actuellement la
tunisie et la tension reste palpable et
manifestations deviennent quotidiennes
aujourd'hui il ya eu une grande
manifestation qui a réuni plus d'un
millier de personnes ça je pars de la
manifestation ici à tunis dans la
capitale mais d'autres manifestations
ont lieu sur le reste du territoire
les manifestants ont tous convergé vers
le parlement un parlement qui a été
barricadée depuis hier soir avec des
barbelés et puis l'armée a été appelée
en renfort objectif protéger ce
parlement alors que les députés sont
tous réunis pour ce vote de confiance
les manifestants n'ont profité pour
obtenir le dénoncer ce gouvernement qui
ne répondent pas favorablement à leurs
attentes et surtout pointé du doigt le
parti islamiste ennahda qui a rendu
responsable de l'instabilité de la crise
politique les dix actuellement la
tunisie
merci bassam chebbi pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de tunis à 10 ans
après le soulèvement populaire le yémen
est plus que jamais en proie à la
violence un pays divisé d'un côté des
outils soutenu par l'iran de l'autre les
forces gouvernementales avec derrière
l'arabie saoudite selon les ong amnesty
international plus de 230 milliers mais
need auraient été tués fin 2019
du fait de la guerre et de la situation
humanitaire la plus grave au monde selon
l'onu
hier de nouvelles manifestations anti
américaines ont eu lieu alors que
washington a récemment placé là
les lions outils sur sa liste des
groupes soutenant le terrorisme rob
actuelle le sentiment anti-américain
s'accentue au yémen plusieurs milliers
de personnes sont une nouvelle fois
descendus dans la rue ce lundi ils
protestent contre l'une des dernières
décisions de donald trump désigner les
outils comme organisation terroriste
le mouvement soutenu par l'iran contrôle
sanaa et une grande partie du nord du
pays une décision une nouvelle fois
contesté par les représentants
politiques
vous ne pouvez pas induire en erreur le
mont qui a découvert votre mensonge
la décision de la précédente
administration américaine de classer le
peuple yéménite comme terroriste est une
décision stupide et elle est tombée
avant qu'elle ne commence
depuis la maison blanche a accueilli un
nouveau locataire
mais la modification de la liste des
organisations terroristes étrangères ne
faisait pas partie des premiers décret
signé par joe biden conscient de
l'urgence de la situation
anthony blinken nouveau secrétaire
d'état a annoncé vouloir étudier le
dossier rapidement mon inquiétude
profonde concernant la désignation qui a
été fait est que du moins en surface
elles ne semblent aboutir à rien de
particulièrement pratique pour faire
avancer les efforts face aux outils et
les ramener à la table des négociations
tout en rendant encore plus difficile
l'acheminement d'une aide humanitaire
aux personnes qui en ont désespérément
besoin
je pense que nous allons proposer de
réexaminer immédiatement cela pour nous
assurer que ce que nous faisons
n'entrave pas le cheminement de l'aide
humanitaire même dans ces circonstances
difficiles
les sanctions rend difficile l'envoi de
denrées humanitaires et le financement
des ong
cette situation fait en effet craindre
une aggravation de la crise humanitaire
au yémen dans un pays où 80% de la
population dépend de l'aide humanitaire
et visite aujourd'hui à bakou la
capitale de l'azerbaïdjan du
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov et s'est entretenu avec son
homologue iranien mohammad javad tarifs
au coeur des discussions
la résolution de la situation dans la
région du sud caucase du haut karabagh
entre azerbaïdjanais et arménien mais
pas seulement
plus de précision avec la correspondance
en russie signé antoine frérot
pendant que le président américain
fraîchement entré en fonctions prend ses
repères à la maison blanche
moscou et téhéran accorder leurs violons
notamment sur le dossier du nucléaire
les deux ministres ont rappelé leur
attachement à l'accord de vienne sur le
nucléaire iranien signe en 2015 accor
duquel donald trump a fait sortir les
états-unis trois ans plus tard
sergueï lavrov a souligné les bonnes
relations entre la russie et l'iran et a
dit espérer faire revenir washington au
sein de l'accord les présidents poutine
et rouani discutent régulièrement
tout cela est bon pour nos relations
bilatérales notamment notre coopération
sur le plan économique commerciale sur
les plans des transports de l'énergie et
notamment en matière d'équipement d'un
nouveau moteur réacteurs nucléaires nous
espérons pouvoir convaincre les états
unis de retourner de revenir à au
respect de cet accord et le respect de
l'ensemble des dispositions de cet
accord
alors bien sûr il n'a pas été question
que de ce sujet les deux hommes ont
aussi parlé du conflit entre l'arménie
et l'azerbaïdjan ou encore de la
situation en syrie
autant de dossiers sur lesquels leur
avis convergent mohammed javad zarif a
de son côté dénoncé les sanctions qui
visent son pays
des sanctions qui empêchent l'iran
d'avoir les relations qui voudraient
avec des pays comme la chine ou encore
la russie les états unis ne doivent pas
saper essayer de saper les relations
entre nous et la russie ils doivent
abandonner leur tentative de nous
empêcher un péché les activités des
sociétés russe et iranienne
leurs sanctions qui ont été imposées de
manière unilatérale contre les pays qui
agissent de manière légale nous allons
répondre à cette décision mais il l'a
créé des obstacles à notre coopération
avec la russie avec la chine
ils doivent abandonner ses tentatives de
créer des obstacles bien sûr une
relation sont très fortes russie et en
appelle donc de concert à sauver
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien est
donc dans le même temps faire tomber les
sanctions américaines contre téhéran
la balle est maintenant dans le camp de
joe biden lui qui était vice président
des états unis au moment de la signature
de ce texte en 2015 à rester sur arte
france dans un instant retour sur la
mobilisation nationale des professeurs
des élèves des infirmières scolaires
pour l'améliorer l'amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail
et puis direction les pays bas où les
violences dues à l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu ne cessent pas a tout de
suite
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise lorsque c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris après
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier
à quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restaurants
c'est pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois ci il faut un
évidemment
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du cadre
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fismes
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france ce qu'on attend
un peu de vous c'est les idées pour en
sortir est votre jugement notamment de
la façon dont cette crise est gérée ce
qui a été montré au cours de la gestion
de cette crise c'est le déficit
d'anticipation pour moi la politique
c'est d'abord d'être efficace dès qu'un
manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
alors que l'économie mondiale à plonger
les bourses elles elles tiennent le coup
un rebond forcément en mars après la
chute importante est tout à fait naturel
mais la hausse qui a poursuivi n'est
absolument pas en relation avec
l'économie aujourd'hui il faut tenir les
marchés à tout prix et pour les tenir
bien vous déversez des liquidités vous
avez une banque centrale qui fixe les
prix on est dans un régime de prix
administrés
on voit finalement une bourse qui
continue de progresser malgré les
mauvaises nouvelles
il va maintenant falloir surtout
retrouver cette corrélation entre
l'économie et les marchés financiers
marchés financiers sont boostés boosté à
la dette boosté à l'argent qui est
imprimé par la banque centrale est la
principale conséquence c'est la
disparition de la valeur de la monnaie
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fallu l'appliquent à la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom aide en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for donc les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dolhain des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on est une gauche plus que
13 ans
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je réponds en
appartement on est énervé donnait le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément au loin
de paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on les passe un
tour de tracteur et nous suivrons
campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs ont
ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente ans
nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut-être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
il est 21h heure française si vous nous
rejoignez excellente soirée à toutes et
à tous sur rt france place à une
deuxième heure d'information tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 26 janvier
plusieurs manifestations d'enseignants
partout en france à l'appel de cinq
syndicats pour appeler à une hausse des
salaires et à de meilleures conditions
de travail
et ce alors que l'incertitude plane sur
une éventuelle fermeture des écoles en
cas de troisième confinement
[Musique]
pas de décision ni d'élocution avant la
fin de la semaine sur une éventuelle
troisième mise sous cloche donc le mot
d'ordre à la veille à d'un énième
conseil de défense sanitaire
il faut d'abord connaître les effets du
couvre-feu et ce alors que le président
du conseil scientifique plaide pour plus
de restrictions même si je cite on n'est
pas à trois jours près
[Musique]
keystone iter a également de l'autre
côté des alpes
l'italie qui vit aussi une crise
politique d'émission cet après-midi de
giuseppe côté le chef du gouvernement
espère obtenir un nouveau mandat du
président sergio matters est là objectif
former une nouvelle coalition pour faire
face si à la vive opposition de son ex
allié centriste
matteo renzi
[Musique]
journée de grève dans l'éducation
nationale plusieurs rassemblements
partout en france dont 1 cet après midi
à paris entre le jardin du luxembourg et
la rue de grenelle
une mobilisation à l'appel de moins 510
cas pour demander une hausse des
salaires et de meilleures conditions de
travail une manifestation sur fond de
défiance envers le ministre de tutelle
jean michel blanquer r et ce alors que
l'incertitude plane quant à une
fermeture des écoles en cas d'un
éventuel recrutement dans le cortège
parisien des enseignants des étudiants
mais aussi des hommes politiques
au micro de tf1 on voit les femmes qui
sont fermés depuis novembre alors que
les étudiants qui sont isolés chez eux
je parle même pas de la détresse des
taux de suicide alors que depuis des
mois et des mois il ya les syndicats
pensent au snes sup mais aussi à l'unef
qui réclament tout simplement de
l'argent dans les universités qui disent
qu'on pourrait ouvrir les facs tenir des
cours avec le respect total des gestes
barrières pour que l'ensemble les
étudiants et des bonnes conditions
d'études
pour ça il faudrait un milliard un
milliard cinq ce qui est rien par
rapport aux 500 milliards qui ont été
données par le gouvernement aux grandes
entreprises depuis le début de la crise
le gouvernement souhaite absolument que
les parents aillent au boulot donc il
faut laisser les écoles ouvertes 1 c'est
le seul objectif mais il n'y a aucun
moyen donner aux enseignants pour
satisfaire les contraintes sanitaires et
permettent de recevoir les élèves dans
des conditions décentes
je parle même pas de l'université où là
c'est une catastrophe absolue pour des
raisons politiques budgétaires les facs
sont fermés ça va faire un nom il ya une
souffrance psychologique des étudiants
qui est énorme qui n'est pas comprise
qui n'est pas soigné par
par le gouvernement et ce gouvernement
est en train de tourner le dos à la
jeunesse pour un pays comme le nôtre
c'est catastrophique
quand on comprend plus la jeunesse c'est
qu'on n'a plus rien à faire au
gouvernement
quand on voit que pendant la crise en
pleine pandémie en 2020 les
milliardaires français ont engrangé 175
milliards de plus c'est à dire deux fois
le budget de l'hôpital public comme l'a
révélé le rapport de l ong oxfam
je pense qu'on a les moyens dans ce pays
d'assurer que nos services publics
auxquels les français tiennent
particulièrement comme c'est le cas de
l'éducation et les moyens de fonctionner
et les moyens de fonctionner sans
prendre de risque ni pour les élèves ni
pour les professeurs dans la période de
pandémie
autre manifestation a cette fois ci à
marseille sur le ministère de
l'éducation le taux de grévistes des
enseignants à s'élever à la mi-journée à
11% sur l'ensemble du territoire
de son côté le snuipp-fsu premier
syndicat du primaire relevé un tiers de
grévistes dans le second degré le snes
fsu estimé ce taux à 40 % rassemblement
également tout à l'heure à toulouse
rennes bordeaux grenoble ou encore
clermont ferrand réactions dans les rues
de la cité phocéenne en a besoin de
moyens pour fonctionner on a besoin
d'eux
on va dire de
de l'appui de notre ministère plutôt que
de sa défiance il est indispensable
aujourd'hui que le système éducatif se
met en ordre de bataille pour accueillir
les élèves les enfants les adolescents
qui dans les années à venir vont subir
les conséquences de la crise économique
et sociale qui est devant nous et qui
est la conséquence de la crise sanitaire
or le ministère de l'éducation nationale
prépare la rentrée 2021
comme si de rien n'était sur sa lancée
en supprimant des postes et en
continuant dans la même direction des
réformes qui aujourd'hui sont
complètement inopportune le gouvernement
et notre ministre de l'éducation n'a pas
pris les mesures nécessaires dès la
rentrée comme ça s'est fait dans
d'autres pays
en recrutant des professeurs des
surveillants des infirmières des
médecins et on a un ministre qui réagit
au coup par coup qui court après
l'épidémie au lieu d'anticiper les
choses et en direct ce soir
pierre priolet secrétaire général ss
effet su professeur de mathématiques au
lycée est celle de toulouse
bonsoir pierre priori merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france
évidemment les chiffres divergent 11 à
12% de grévistes selon le ministère 30 à
40% d'après les syndicats qui croire à
toulouse où vous êtes ça a donné quoi
dans la rue tout à leur écoute et nous
avons pour le second degré constaté un
taux de grévistes de 40%
nous avons procédé à un sondage sur une
cinquantaine d'établissements sur
lesquels sont croqués guérini et un
panel de professeurs de 1500 personnes
donc on est largement dans les clous
pour une fiabilité qui est bien
supérieur en fait c'est le sondage
politique donc voilà notre taux est tout
à fait fia le rectorat n'a pas
communiqué à ma connaissance de chiffres
on avait beaucoup de politiques dans le
cortège parisien véritable soutien selon
vous au simple récupération politique
par écoutez nous on est dans la
situation de demander que le système
éducatif devienne une vraie priorité
dans ce pays en camp
faites-en correctement ses personnels
lui donnant les moyens de fonctionner il
faudra bien qu'un jour ou l'autre une
alternative politique permette de
concrétiser ces orientations ses
aspirations de la profession qui pour
l'instant ne trouvent aucun débouché
avec le pouvoir qui est actuellement en
place on parle beaucoup d'un grenelle
des enseignants a un grand rendez-vous
du nom issu de la rue où se situe votre
ministère de tutelle ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour beaucoup de
syndicats ce ne serait pas suffisant
pourquoi quels sont les points de
désaccord écoutez concernant le volet de
l'éducation nous avons fait le constat
arrivent d'autres d'ailleurs qu'il
s'agissait essentiellement d'une
opération de communication du ministre
j'en veux pour preuve les montants qui
ont été annoncées dans le cadre de la
revalorisation soit disant historique
dont jean michel blanquer reparle en
réalité depuis au moins trois ans il
s'agit pour l'année 2000 21 de 400
millions d'euros c'est extrêmement peu
le président macro avait déclaré il ya
un an si on veut revaloriser les
enseignants il faut mettre 10 milliards
sur la table
ça donne un peu une idée de la manière
dont les négociations se sont ouvertes
dans le cadre de se donner pour ce qui
concerne notre monde organisation de la
l'ont quittée voilà parce que c'est une
véritable mascarade on va demander à des
stars à des personnalités médiatiques de
cautionner une politique qu'en réalité
ils ne verront jamais évident meurent
parce qu'ils ne la vivent pas donc on
est loin loin du compte
et encore une fois le ministre
fanfaronne en laissant de côté
70 % des enseignants qui n'auront
strictement aucune augmentation de
salaire alors est ce que vous avez prévu
d'amener de nouvelles journées de
mobilisation
écoutez vous savez comme moi que le
contexte s'est terminée en complique
énormément les choses c'est d'ailleurs
une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
sommes satisfaits ce soit de la
participation de nos collègues parce que
c'était pas évident de se mobiliser dans
un contexte où chacun est très inquiet
les suites
elles vont se débattre dans les salles
des professeurs on verra aussi en
fonction de la situation sanitaire des
réponses qu'apporte le ministre comment
on peut les envisagez vous parler du
contexte sanitaire justement parle
beaucoup d'un éventuel troisième
confinement selon vous
sir confinement il y a les écoles
doivent-elles restée ouverte c'est tout
le départ du moment confinement dur sans
les écoles confinement plus souple avec
les écoles war couvre-feu que les cas
pour l'instant nous sommes en couvre feu
avance à 18 heures et avec plaisir que
nous avons fait le constat au printemps
que le confinement dur alors qu'on
n'avait pas d'autre solution dans les
gaines conscient a quand même produit
dans la jeunesse des difficultés
maintenant dont nous voyons les
conséquences des difficultés
d'apprentissage nous coller une forte à
faire depuis la rentrée de septembre
pour remettre les élèves dans les
apprentissages aussi de combler les
retards ils sont d'ailleurs pas parvenu
l'alternance dans les lycées d'un pas
permis de traiter des programmes qui
étaient par ailleurs extrêmement chargé
nous on est favorable évidemment parce
que les écoles restent ouvertes sur ce
point là nous sommes en accord avec le
ministre là nous avons une vraie
divergence c'est sur les moyens qu'il
faut y mettre pour que la rendre
possible aujourd'hui dans l'académie de
toulouse nous avons quatre
établissements du second degré une
dizaine d'écoles du premier degré qui
sont qui sont fermés tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas pris les
dispositions nécessaires pour assurer un
protocole sanitaire qui protège les
élèves les professeurs et qui limite la
circulation du virus
les jean michel blanquer surtout
renforcer sa communication plus que son
protocole justement le protocole
sanitaire comme moi ce que vous faites
pour le respecter dans votre
établissement chez vous à tous aux mains
très concrètement dans notre
établissement nous fonctionnons en deux
niveaux
donc les élèves alternent d'une semaine
sur l'autre là c'est une possibilité qui
est offerte au lycée sur son 10 % des
lycées dans le pays ont d'ailleurs
adopté cette modalité là aujourd'hui
tout le vrai point noir ce sont les
collèges
nous avons des collèges dans l'académie
à plus de 1200 élèves donc en termes de
taille ce sont c'est l'équivalent de la
mise et simplement le ministre et le
recteur et 600 me faire une distinction
un peu absurde entre deux établissements
de taille comparable au simple motif qui
a un qui s'appelle un collège et
l'autralie c est donc on a des collèges
qui continue à tourner à plein
aucune distance à la cantine avec un
grande difficulté à faire respecter les
distances dans les couloirs en rien le
port du masque c'est vrai il est bien
respectée mais on nous remonte des
situations il ya plus de gel
hydroalcoolique
on est dans l'incapacité réalité de
tracer correctement les gains contact
voilà d'ailleurs des désaccords sur le
décompte des ailes qui seront testés
positifs au coït justement il va y avoir
des tests qui vont être mis en place à
part par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale dans dans les établissements
des établissements qui pour certains
fonctionnant en présentiel autres en
distance yale demi-groupe admis groupe
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur blanc caire a évoquée pourquoi
pas d'instaurer des demies groupe en
collège dès le troisième la quatrième
vous en pensez quoi s'il devait y avoir
un nouveau profitant de ce principe
favorite en cours mais là aussi et de le
faire de ne pas priver complètement les
élus scolarité parce qu'on sait très
bien qu'un appartement basculera dans un
enseignement à distance va retomber dans
les mêmes problématiques au printemps
mais pas plus truc au printemps les
professeurs ne sont pas plus équipés
qu'au printemps les élèves n'ont plus
personne ne soit que cette situation là
après j'entends bien la nécessité de
prendre des mesures sanitaires mais on
pense au lieu de dire qu'on va permettre
au collège de passer en hybride où en
est le lien dans les groupes celui
d'istres a déjà promis en réalité dès le
11 novembre
il faut le rendre effectif aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
pierre priori je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général s'est fait sur et
professeur de mathématiques au lycée est
celle à toulouse on vient d'évoquer un
éventuel reconfirme ans pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de kobe 19
tout comme les vaccins pour lutter
million cent mille français sont
vaccinés tout comme les masques
également les problèmes malgré la
production made in france le secteur
public s'approvisionne toujours hors de
l'hexagone
katia technique en france on a des idées
et on a aussi des masques restaurer nos
capacités de production fut laborieux
puisque l'une des dernières usines de
masques avait fermé en 2018
nous étions donc dépendants d un parent
étranger d'où la pénurie subie en début
de pandémie
mais désormais la production française a
repris et conformément au souhait d'
emmanuel macron fin mars 2020 la france
a récupéré sa souveraineté avant la
crise nous produisions en france 3,3
millions de masques par semaine fin
avril nous serons à plus de 10 millions
nous aurons plus que triplé en quelques
semaines et nous continuerons cet effort
pour continuer la multiplication de nos
capacités de production et je veux que
d'ici la fin de l'année nous ayons
obtenu justement cette indépendance
pleine et entière des centaines
d'entreprises produisent désormais des
masques en france allant du géant du
luxe à la manufacture traditionnel en
passant par la start up et la capacité
de production multipliée par 30 en moins
d'un an a atteint les 100 millions de
masques sanitaires par semaine certaines
de ces sociétés sont aidées par l'état
et pour soutenir la filière l'initiative
savoir faire ensemble regroupe les
acteurs du textile mettre en place des
solutions pour faciliter les liens entre
donneurs d'ordre et fournisseurs booster
l'écosystème de la fabrication française
en favorisant les liens entre membres du
réseau
on peut crier cocorico mais il ya un hic
car étonnamment cela ne signifie pas que
la commande publique favorise les matchs
fabriqué en france une enquête de nos
collègues de france info révèle que les
collectivités région département se
fournissent en masque parfois produits
en chine en tunisie en pologne
ou alors s'adresse à des entreprises
locales mais qui en réalité
et revendre des protections fabriqués à
des milliers de kilomètres
des masques chinois s'invite au conseil
général du var des masques vietnamiens à
la métropole nice côte d'azur comment
est ce possible
plusieurs raisons expliquent cette
importation d'une part le critère du
prix de l'autre les critères techniques
particuliers pouvant être exigée dans
l'appel d'offres et de plus les marchés
publics doivent se plier aux règles de
concurrence européennes obligatoire et
le pays de fabrication n'entre pas dans
les critères de sélection
ainsi la france retient d'une main ce
qu'elle se voit obligé de repousser de
l'autre une sorte de mascarade
mais qu'est ce donc que cette
souveraineté européenne celle là même
qui nous supprime la possibilité de
souveraineté nationale
une situation décrite comme
schizophrénique par les syndicats ou
fédérations du textile alors comment
opté pour la préférence nationale sans
se faire attaquer par les entreprises
étrangères pour non respect des règles
de concurrence en augmentant par exemple
le poids des critères sociaux et
environnementaux à l'appel d'offres et
la france pourrait devenir imbattable
son bilan carbone en bandoulière est
actuellement les discussions sont vives
le ministère de l'économie et les
acteurs du secteur réfléchissent à un
billet pour valoriser les produits
locaux
messieurs les commanditaires à vos
marques au royaume-uni triste record est
une première en europe le pays qui a
déjà vacciné près de 7 millions de
personnes vient de franchir le seuil
symbolique des cent mille morts du côté
de 19
la population britannique actuellement
confiné à cause notamment d'un variant
du strass cov deux considérés comme plus
contagieux et potentiellement plus
mortelle le premier ministre boris
johnson dit assumer ses choix des riches
ghost je tiens à répéter que je suis
profondément désolé pour chaque bille
perdu bien sûr en tant que premier
ministre j'assume la pleine
responsabilité de tout ce que le
gouvernement a fait garde moniteur
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
avons vraiment fait tout ce que nous
pouvions
et continuons à faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour minimiser les pertes de vie
de la f1 et les souffrances dans ce qui
a été une étape très très difficile et
une crise tout aussi compliqué stage
les autres pays européens un pacte est
également par la crise sanitaire ou les
restrictions ont parfois du mal à passer
par une certaine frange de la population
illustration aux pays bas où beaucoup
craignent ce soir une quatrième nuit
d'émeutes clément barbe et au lendemain
d'une nouvelle nuit d'émeutes
le centre ville de rotterdam sont
défigurés magasins pillés vitrines
brisées et arrêt de bus cassés les
habitants constatent les dégâts avec
amertume
ce n'est pas se battre pour la liberté
c'est triste des gens pleurent parce
qu'ils ne se sentent plus à la maison
les manifestants protestent contre
l'instauration d'un couvre-feu entre 21h
et 4h30 du matin ces violences inédites
dans le pays depuis 40 ans se sont
soldées par l'arrestation de plus de 180
personnes selon le chef de la police au
moins 10 membres des forces de l'ordre
ont été blessés
ces émeutes n'ont rien à voir avec le
droit fondamental de manifester respect
pour tous les collègues qui ont eu du
mal pendant trois nuits
de son côté le premier ministre
démissionnaire mark rutte eux a réagi en
affirmant que 99% des néerlandais
soutiennent les mesures restrictives de
liberté pour commencer ces émeutes sont
inadmissibles et les personnes normales
s'en aperçoive avec horreur
vous pouvez vraiment vous demandez ce
qui est passé par la tête de ces gens
cela n'a rien à voir avec de la
protestation
c'est de la violence criminelle et nous
la traiterons comme tel le gouvernement
assure qu'il ne fera pas marche arrière
malgré les protestations depuis le début
de la pandémie au moins treize mille six
cents personnes sont décédées ducobu 19
aux pays bas on continue de parler de la
hollande avec thierry lebreton président
de l'association à des français et pays
bas
bonsoir tirer le breton merci de
répondre à nos questions est ce qu'il
faut craindre une quatrième nuit
d'émeutes ce soir ça avait commencé
samedi
est-ce que ça va crescendo ou pas il ya
une vraie inquiétude vous l'avez noté on
peut pas savoir ce qui va se passer mais
c'est surtout effectivement
l'instauration du couvre-feu samedi
dernier qui était finalement le
déclencheur de ces de ces violences qui
reste quand même relativement limité
tout de même mais elles sont nouvelles
dans le pays et c'est pour ça que ça
choque le premier ministre marque route
dit que 99% des néerlandais soutiennent
les mesures restrictives de liberté pour
lutter contre le courant des virus
comment alors expliquer cette colère qui
sont les 1 % restants qui sont les
manifestants leur profil c'est quoi
c'est vrai d'abord qu'il ya un vrai
soutien massif finalement à la coalition
gouvernementale même si l ellipse
ionnaires ce qui effectivement on réagit
et c'est probablement des jeunes qui
sont évidemment eux mêmes aussi très
impactées par par les mesures ou en tout
cas par la situation depuis des mois
entiers on les a pas entendus finalement
ces jeunes et donc pour eux c'est
probablement à un moyen de 2 serait de
se faire entendre de manière violente et
donc d'où la réaction effectivement très
unanime de la classe politique pour sûr
sur ce s'indigner sur ses fesses sur ces
violences évidemment au delà de
s'indigner le premier ministre mark
rutte
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
prochainement pour faire face à ces
violences et il pourrait changer de
politique faire volte-face revenir sur
l'instauration du couvre-feu
ça sert effectivement c'est probablement
la mesure qui a été déclenché aux mais
je pense pas qu'il va revenir dessus
parce que d'abord encore une fois il ya
un soutien massif de l'opinion à
l'ensemble de ces mesures
donc c'est tout simplement peut-être
faire je dois faire preuve de fermeté
mais aussi toujours très à l'écouté de
ces jeunes
et puis tout simplement continuer à
parler et à agir et à dialoguer avec
toutes les parties
on rentre dans une période un petit peu
délicate puisque finalement les
élections nationales auront lieu dans un
peu plus d'un an dans moins de deux mois
maintenant effectivement à la mi mars
donc les choses se vont se précipiter un
petit peu
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
situation de violence ce qu'elle
pourrait intervenir par exemple en
france
en cas de troisième confinement par
exemple je ne sais pas si les choses
sont comparables et les violences dont
on parle effectivement sont aussi
peut-être pas aussi importante qu'on en
parle en france c'est vrai que beaucoup
de villes ont été impactés et c'est là
qu'elles sont pas négligeables mais
peut-être que l'ampleur qu'on en donne
est peut-être moins important donc je ne
peux pas non plus comparer avec ce qui
se passe en france aussi on regarde un
peu ce qui se passait dans le passé
c'était souvent effectivement en marche
d'autres sujets de mécontentement comme
par exemple le seul et gilet jaune mais
non ça ne peut pas vous répondre
par rapport à ces violences qui ont eu
lieu aux pays-bas vous vite que beaucoup
de villes sont impactés quelle ville
exactement on parle évidemment
d'amsterdam c'est david n'a plus connu
est ce que d'autres villes comme
rotterdam eindhoven la ngp ringot
ping'an son nom sont impactés toutes les
villes c'est cette fois le profil des
ddd ville les villes urbaines entre
guillemets ou plus rurales non ce sont
aussi des villes qui sont moins dans le
centre des pays bas comme sous le par
exemple ou à eindhoven où vous l'avez
évoqué mais celle qui a marqué les
esprits français si rotterdam
effectivement où il ya une concentration
de celle de deux jeunes qui a qui ont
fait un instant nous dégage donc
retenez bien sûr comme saddam également
où elle et les grandes villes et pas
vraiment profil filmant les commerçants
sont maintenant fermés ils subissent les
fracas des des manifestants est ce que
c'est une double peine pour eux
dans quel état d'esprit ils sont les
commerçants néerlandais habile ne sont
pas surtout habitué à ce genre de
manifestations et de violences donc
évidemment ils sont ils sont ils sont
choqués comme je crois à l'ensemble de
la population
et comme ce fut le cas d'ailleurs en
france on peut l'imaginer
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
tirées le breton je rappelle que vous
êtes le précise le président de
l'association français des pays-bas dans
le reste de l'actualité au brésil la
capitale de l'amazone y pensait être
sorti d'affaires
la pandémie grâce à à l'immunité
collective
ce n'est pas le cas la situation qui
s'aggrave à manaus la ville est
l'épicentre d'un cluster qui inquiète
les autorités brésiliennes ainsi que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
subito sont saturés face à un rebond des
contaminations dues aux variants
amazonien walid ben une tente un abri
pour un grand objectif sauver des vies
indigènes peut-on lire sur la pancarte
de cette pharmacie de campagne les
habitants de manaus attentifs aux
conseils des infirmiers et soignante
face à une deuxième vague préoccupante
tour med est bon a essayé se tait qui
contient du citron de l'ail et du manga
ratahya le manga ratahya est appelée
gingembre sur la langue des blancs il
sert à se gargariser et en prendre un
peu pour donner l'immunité aux gens
l'immunité et plus largement l'immunité
collective une doctrine qui fait débat
au brésil et dans le monde
après la publication de cet article par
la revue science
on y apprend que 76 % de la population
de manaus avait contracté le virus en
octobre 2020 avec l'espoir justement de
laisser le virus se propage et au
maximum au sein de la population et qui
au-delà d'un certain seuil ne pourra
plus atteindre qu'un être humain
stratégie qui ne semble pas payé face
notamment variant venu d'amazonie manaus
a déjà vécu plus de 3000 en termes en
janvier le mois le plus meurtrier depuis
le début de la pandémie officiellement
le virus est responsable de presque la
moitié des décès je suis
particulièrement inquiète pour les
prochaines semaines dans toute notre
région en particulier en amérique du
nord et du sud
de nombreux hôpitaux fonctionnent à
pleine capacité ou presque et les
rapports de manaus au brésil illustre ce
qui se passe lorsqu'un système de santé
n'a pas la capacité suffisante pour
faire face à la rapidité des nouvelles
infections sur des hôpitaux surchargés
avec une pénurie de lits et d'oxygène
alors que le brésil a débuté sa
vaccination seulement le 17 janvier un
pays qui compte plus de 210 millions
d'habitants son président jacques bolle
sonar aux réticents à l'adoption de
mesures restrictives est pointé du doigt
[Musique]
une immunité collective choisit
également par la suède la
grande-bretagne ou encore par le
gouvernement de donald trump
tous ont finalement décidé de faire
machine arrière
les etats unis pays le plus touché au
monde la grande bretagne nation
européenne la plus meurtrie fin décembre
le roi de suède à lui reconnu son échec
à la télévision même si les vaccins
commençaient à protéger les plus
vulnérables nous n'atteindrons aucun
niveau d'immunité de la population ou d'
immunité collective en 2021
et même si cela se produit dans quelques
poches de quelques pays
cela ne protégera pas les gens dans le
monde immunité collective vaccin pour l'
oms le respect des gestes barrières
restent pour l'heure le seul moyen
efficace de se protéger contre le virus
restait sur arte france dans un instant
direction l'italie où un nouveau
gouvernement va être formé et suite à la
démission de giuseppe qaunt et partir
pour mieux revenir
c'est le pari risqué de l'ancien chef du
gouvernement quête de nouvelles
coalitions
focus sur les états unis avec un tube
hayden déterminée face au kobus 19 a
tout de suite
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fans ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom aide en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for donc les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux hanul à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
compte à peine françois vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview il n'y a pas
une façon plus pauvres de défendre un
système que de dire qu'il est moins pire
que le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative en sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france il est 21h30
heure française et l'info continue créé
sanitaire en italie est doublée d'une
crise politique d'émission tout à
l'heure de giuseppe côté le chef du
gouvernement espère obtenir un nouveau
mandat de la part du président serge
matériel pour tenter de former une
nouvelle coalition
pierre jan masaryk démissionné pour
mieux reconstruire c'est la stratégie
politique de giuseppe compter en quête
d'une nouvelle majorité
le premier ministre italien espère
garder la confiance de sergio matar est
là en obtenant un mandat de son
président pour former un nouveau
gouvernement
le troisième depuis 2018 dans un pays en
pleine crise politique et sanitaire
une instabilité accentuée par la
défection du parti allié italien vivats
de matteo renzi le 13 janvier dernier
l'ex chef du gouvernement qui s'est
montré très critique sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
ce départ obligé giuseppe comptait
obtenir la confiance des parlementaires
la semaine dernière pour sauver son
gouvernement de coalition
d'abord devant les députés puis au sénat
où il l'emporté d'une courte tête depuis
le premier ministre a tenté de rallier à
sa cause des élus indépendants pour lui
assurer de nouveau la majorité est ainsi
restée aux commandes
son succès pour l'heure le premier
ministre sortant peut compter sur le
soutien du parti démocrate et du
mouvement 5 étoiles mais pour combien de
temps encore en direct ce soir sur arte
france
enrico letta ancien président du conseil
italien ancien chef du gouvernement donc
et président de l'institut jacques
delors
enrico letta bonasera merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france vous avez donc été le
chef du gouvernement italien entre le 28
avril 2013 et le 22 février 2014
vous étiez au sein d'une coalition menée
par le [ __ ] le parti démocrate de matteo
renzi qu'est ce que vous pensez du pari
de giuseppe côté partir pour mieux
revenir alors qu'il est poussé par
matteo renzi je pense que c'était le
seul choix c'est le choix qu'il avait la
peau s'il y avait la possibilité de
faire mais je pense que c'est une crise
grave incompréhensible dans un moment
dramatique comme le moment qu'on est en
train de vivre dans tout pays européens
avec la crise sanitaire
franchement que le pays soit bloqué dans
une crise de toute politique ça fait
désormais déjà une dizaine de jours le
pays dans une crise politique et ça va
continuer pour déjouer des jours et ça
va rendre les autorités de l'état et des
régions même moi capable je pense de
contrer les problèmes de la pandémie
parce que les gens sont occupés
aujourd'hui s'est disputée sur la
politique franchement je trouve ça
irresponsable et la cause est surtout
dans la personne de matières ainsi
l'ancien crise et président du conseil
italien qui aujourd'hui à la tête d'un
petit parti est en train de bloquer tout
je pense pour des raisons de politique
personnelle et franchement je ne vois
pas où ça peut aller sinon dans une
aggravation de la situation politique
politicienne donc à vous entendre qu'ils
aient à la meilleure place pour s'allier
à l'ancien premier ministre alors qu'il
l'a déclaré il cherche une coalition il
est en train de parler avec les députés
avec les sénateurs et est en train de
parler avec les forces politiques ce
n'est pas simple parce que la droite et
la droite souverainiste italienne anti
européennes sortent les fortes au
parlement les sortes dans le pays elle
veut des élections
donc il y a aussi un petit risque mais
je pense plus que petit
que le blocage politique et l'absence
d'une solution amène peut-être à des
élections le plus tôt que possible et je
pense que ce serait un problème
gravissime pour un pays qui ne peut pas
se permettre
franchement des mois de blocage mois de
campagne électorale
on a à contrer une pandémie avec des
problèmes en plus de récession
économique qui sont super grave donc
franchement incompréhensible que cette
politique politicienne bloque tout
maintenant vous m'avez devancé sur cette
question qui venait justement au sujet
des élections législatives la coalition
si coalition il ya si giuseppe qu'on
arrive à la voir est-ce qu'elle serait
solide ou fragiles et du coup quid de
futures élections législatives
prochainement c'est donc une réalité
selon vous je pense que le parlement va
faire le possible pour éviter une
élection anticipée et le président de
litres de même en plus comme vous savez
il ya mis un référendum ali qui a coupé
est rendu le parlement plus petit donc
une grande partie des actuels
parlementaire ne vont pas revenir ce qui
est toujours une grande poussée à ne pas
anticiper les élections naturellement et
le président de la république aussi veut
éviter ça mais le blocage est là
derrière le coin donc je pense que ce
n'est pas une hypothèse impossible si la
crise continue pour des jours et des
jours sans solution comment on peut
expliquer cette instabilité politique
chronique en italie
plus de 70 71 gouvernement si je ne
m'abuse depuis 1946 la chose est liée au
système qui est d'un système
parlementaire pur un système dans lequel
donc le parlement est le centre de tout
et dans notre système italien la
représentativité est la première
priorité de la loi électorale plus que
l'efficacité de l'action du gouvernement
c'est un système doc qui a des avantages
d'un système qui dans la possibilité de
faire en sorte que tout
forces politiques soient représentés et
donc tous soient associés au moins à la
vie institutionnelle il ya une énorme
différence avec la france qui a un
système qui préfèrent la gouvernabilité
au lieu de la représentativité en france
il ya deux forces politiques très fortes
qui sont très peu présentes ou absente
du parlement et ce n'est pas le cas chez
nous et des évidemment tout ça a créé
des problèmes de gouvernabilité on a
cherché de changer les choses avec un
référendum il y a quatre ans qui n'a pas
eu un effet positif et l'as la loi
électorale n'aide pas non plus la
fragmentation de force politique
là aussi mais de pas et je pense aussi
que la crise est liée au moment
particulièrement difficile que le pays
est en train de vivre avec la pandémie
avec la récession économique tant que je
trouve que ce soit un moment vraiment
très grave très difficile dans la vie de
mon pays dernière question rapidement à
enrico letta si au final il devait y
avoir des élections législatives
prochainement quelle partie
en tirer bénéfice ce qui a un parti qui
était plus en avant que l'autre on sait
qui est le mouvement ching quest ix les
cinq étoiles de deux j'ai oublié son nom
le maillot de 10 miles
il ya également la lega nord de la ligue
du nord de l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur qui pourrait
et bien tiré son épingle du jeu il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui il y a les deux
leaders de la droite souverainiste qui
ont reçu un cadeau à l'eau 'cadeau'
vienne domaine ce qui a fait tomber le
gouvernement et donc donne aux à la
droite souverainiste une chance qu'elle
n'imaginait pas avoir ça ne m'atteint
savigny et donc salvini et meloni qui
sont les deux leaders de la droite
souverainiste
il est évident que s'il y avait une
élection mais je le répète ce n'est pas
encore le cas ce serait une élection
entre deux dans le centre gauche et les
5 étoiles
d'un côté et la droite souverainiste de
l'autre et à les petits partis de centre
qui devrait choisir de quel côté se
mettre et à la fin les italiens auraient
à choisir et ce serait je pense une
élection très très serré merci à marie
quoi l'état d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes un
ancien président du conseil italien
autrement dit un ancien premier ministre
italien et puis vous êtes également le
président de l'institut jacques delors
une discussion téléphonique très attendu
celle entre eux joe biden et vladimir
poutine qui se sont entretenus tout à
l'heure au niveau de plusieurs sujets
notamment le traité new start de
désarmement nucléaire bilatérale
il expire début février le président
américain évoque une prolongation à 2,50
le chef du kremlin de son côté appelle à
une normalisation des relations
russo-américaines je cite dans l'intérêt
de toute la communauté internationale
nous sommes enfin parvenus à un accord
visant à proroger le traité start 3 ce
qui est sans doute la seule bonne
nouvelle que nous ayons récemment
entendu à propos des relations entre les
etats-unis et la russie
pourtant le fait qu'elle soit la seule
n'enlève rien à son importance c'est sûr
il s'agit d'un évènement d'intérêt
majeur qui à plusieurs dimensions
poignante la schtroumpfette étant donné
le contexte actuel il est évident qu'il
était très difficile de parvenir à cet
accord tant par manque de temps qu'à
cause du film a des relations
bilatérales qui après la passation de
pouvoirs aux états unis comme d'hab'
relation aucunement changé
il est très bien que nous commencions
notre coopération avec la nouvelle
administration l'administration byden
sur ce geste positif est symbolique et
de nouvelles perspectives afin de faire
progresser une relation dans d'autres
domaines également
joe biden qui travaillent donc sur la
politique extérieure américaine 46e
président des états unis qui travaillait
aussi sur la politique intérieure
dossiers prioritaires la crise sanitaire
nicolas petit
depuis son arrivée à la maison blanche
il en a fait sa priorité la lutte contre
le coc vide 19 joe biden veulent a mené
tambour battant
il s'est d'ailleurs fixé un horizon cet
été je suis convaincu que d'ici l'été
nous serons sur la bonne voie pour nous
diriger vers l'immunité collective et
accroître l'accès aux personnes qui ne
font pas partie de la première vague de
vaccination en allant jusqu'aux enfants
je suis convaincu de la manière dont
nous allons mettre cela en place
mais ce que nous allons faire est bien
et je pense que nous pouvons y arriver
pour parvenir à cet objectif joe biden
veut mener une campagne de vaccination
intensive
après avoir dans un premier temps évoqué
le chiffre d'un million de personnes
vaccinées quotidiennement au cours des
100 prochains jours
il a lundi revu ses ambitions à la
hausse et annoncé un million et demi de
vaccinations quotidiennes dans cette
opération de grande envergure
joe biden a reçu le soutien des géants
de la grande distribution amazon et
wallmart qui ont proposé leur aide
logistique pour accélérer le processus
joe biden peut également compter sur
l'immunologue anthony fauci conseiller
qu'ovide de la maison blanche qui se dit
libéré de pouvoir tourner la page de
l'administration trump
au sein de laquelle il se considérait
comme le rabat joie de service il est
très clair que certaines choses qui ont
été dites que ce soit à propos de choses
comme hydroxy chloroquine et d'autre de
ce genre était vraiment gênante parce
qu'elles n'étaient pas fondés sur des
faits scientifiques des idées que vous
puissiez venir ici et parler de ce que
vous savez des preuves de la science
laissez la science parler c'est un peu
un sentiment de libération
s'il est trop tôt pour pouvoir juger des
effets du décret anti qu'ovide signé par
le nouveau président dès son investiture
mercredi dernier les chiffres des
contaminations sont en recul depuis un
peu plus de 15 jours un signe
encourageant mais joe biden ne veut pas
faire dans la démagogie
lundi il a déclaré que les états unis
pourraient atteindre entre 600 milles et
660 1000 décès liés au corona virus est
en direct depuis à new york avec nous
dans cette édition chadwick moore
journaliste politique c'est notre
rubrique
vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir chadwick moore merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france avec à
dubaï donne place donc à une nouvelle
politique sanitaire aux etats-unis une
politique qui contraste avec celle de
donald trump section très différentes
administrations baden a produit est 100
millions de vaccins mais 5 millions de
vaccins ce n'est pas 100 millions de
vaccinés une version de vaccins en cinq
jours mais il faut deux des sports à une
vaccination complète sa dose à ce jour 3
3 millions de personnes ont reçu les
deux doses pour vacciner la nation
stration trump les deux vaccinations par
jour l administration reagan en cache
beaucoup d'informations que
l'administration précédente n'aurait pas
pu faire autrement mais les médias sont
plus prudents avec joe biden
cette administration problème sur la
ligne 3 semaines précédentes mais elle
le fait et c'est le projet de joe biden
maintenant et la lustration précédente
atteignez 100 millions un million de
vaccinations par jour
vous l'avez dit 100 millions de vaccins
distribués dans les 100 premiers jours
du mandat de joe biden les précommandes
de sérum commandé par donald trump qui
sont loin d'être fabriqués donc du coup
à vous entendre
c'est difficilement réalisable ce serait
donc un excès de confiance c'est cela de
combien de vaccins dispose
d'administration d'alten et la
lustration bail d'occupation se le dire
donc on ne le savent pas
l'administration beit-el
l'administration trucks en disant qu'il
ne leur ont pas donné toutes les
informations nécessaires alors que
l'administration de troll respecter ses
objectifs
l'administration baden signé plus de
trente décret présidentiel cela passe
par la présence des femmes transgenres
dans le sport jusqu'à l'annulation de
projets de paille lines et au canada
trois présidents précédents tout ce sont
les quatre à cinq décrets présent seul
lors de leur premier jour 1 au pouvoir
mais l'équipe hayden se concentre sur
des sujets tels que je demande les
personnes transgenres dans la crise et
se désintéressent de la vaccination mais
ne s'agit pas que des vaccins il fut
également organiser la logistique avec
le centre de vaccination le personnel
tout seul à parler des centres de
vaccination la célèbre enseigne de
grande surface à wal mart propose des
centres de vaccination dans des
supermarchés on évoque également une
aide logistique d'amazon
comment est ce que la population
américaine voit c'est main tendue de la
part de géant
industriels ou du web le vaccin de la
grippe par exemple peut être reçus dans
des centres super martiaux il ya des
pharmacies dans les magasins walmart
donc cela m'a rien dit ni oui c'est une
bonne chose si ces revendeurs veulent
aider mais pour le public américain cela
n'a rien de nouveau
effectivement amazon pourrait t'aider à
la logique de sa part jean par
s'attendait tellement de plus cela
n'aurait rien d'extraordinaire pour les
américains et les revendeurs américains
il ya eu un cas de variants brésilien
qui a été détectée on parle évidemment
du variant sud africain ou du variant du
courant d'un virus britannique et
maintenant on évoque un variant
californien les vaccins justement alors
on parle cette politique de vaccination
voulue par par joe biden est-ce qu'ils
seraient toujours efficaces face à ces
nouvelles souches qu'est ce qui se dit
aux états unis à ce sujet vaccin protège
au moins contre les variants brésilien
élévation bettany les ailes aux
mutations salé pas inattendu et les
virus ce monde est en fait il s'agit
presque d'effrayer la population
lorsqu'on parle d' immunité collective
eh bien il faut savoir que cela ne sont
pas forcément que tout le monde doit
être vacciné la réalité c'est qu'une
majorité des américains ont sans doute
eu déjà le virus sans même le savoir
la vaste majorité des gens qu'il
contracte le corner virus n'est
quasiment pas de symptômes
beaucoup de personnes sont déjà entre
guillemets vacciner car ils ont déjà été
en contact avec le virus et l'ideo de
vouloir vacciner toute la population
avec ces nouveaux variants qui
apparaissent c'est une autre chose
il semble pour le moment en tout cas que
ces vaccins restent efficaces ces
vaccins bien sûr produits en atteint un
record qui pourrait peut-être avoir des
effets secondaires on n'est pas sûr en
tout cas voilà ce que les entreprises 10
pour le moment on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure je change de sujet je ne parle
que de vaccins on a paré de la politique
intérieure de joe biden qui travaille
également sur la politique extérieure il
ya eu un échange téléphonique tout à
l'heure entre le 46e président des états
unis et vladimir poutine
les deux hommes qui se sont entendus sur
le traité new start de désarmement
nucléaire bilatérale
comment est-ce qu'il faudra voir dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois la relation
entre washington et moscou
ce qui lui apparaît sous
l'administration entrante une déposition
l'hostilité entre la russie et l'otan et
la russie seraient encore le grand
méchant de la guerre froide
mais en fait la situation est plus
compliquée que cela l'administration
obama n'était pas très juste il envers
la russie tient sur l'administration à
faire de l'administration tremblay
médias l'ont prétendu que continuent
dans la lancée de l'administration obama
alors sans doute qu'il aura
effectivement les accords sur l'armement
nucléaire
il ya eu des frictions entre obama et
poutine
c'est la montre je pense que la façon
dont les médias représentent des
situations s'était notamment visible
sous le mandat trump change en fonction
de la situation donc on ne parle pas de
copinage entre êtres entre baden et foot
il n'ya plus de théorie du complot
et selon laquelle joe biden pourrait
renverser la démocratie aux états unis
et c'est tout simplement parce qu' il
aime bien le jeu bail de ne pouvoir
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
celle d'août moore depuis les états unis
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
politique dans le reste de l'actualité
jour de fête nationale aujourd'hui en
inde le 26 janvier marquent
l'anniversaire de l'entrée en vigueur de
la constitution indienne en 1950
consécutive à l'indépendance de l'inde
vis-à-vis de la grande-bretagne un
événement éclipsé par la manifestation
de milliers d'agriculteurs indien de
nombreux incidents ont éclaté avec la
police
au moins un manifestant a été tué
françois 10 km h parade militaire géante
ce mardi à new delhi sous le regard du
premier ministre indien la reine g audi
chars des troupes des fils mais à
quelques kilomètres de là une changement
d'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
la police indienne chargée tirent des
gaz lacrymogènes en face des milliers
d'agriculteurs indiens manifestent avec
leurs tracteurs en ce 26 janvier la
police tire des gaz lacrymogènes sur
nous et nous frappent avec des bâtons on
voulait protester pacifiquement avec les
couleurs de notre drapeau national
on n'a rien fait de mal c'est la police
qui a tiré des gaz lacrymogènes et nous
a frappés avec des matraques
les autorités avaient pourtant autorisé
la manifestation à condition de laisser
le défilé militaire se dérouler comme
prévu jusqu'à la fin mais rapidement les
forces de sécurité ont été débordés et
les agriculteurs sont parvenus à forcer
certains barrages dressés à l'entrée de
new delhi
[Applaudissements]
des milliers d'entre eux sont même
parvenus à occuper le fort rouge l'un
des monuments les plus emblématiques et
les plus sécurisés de delhi depuis fin
novembre des dizaines de milliers
d'agriculteurs comme sur les principaux
axes routiers aux portes de la capitale
indienne
ils réclament la révocation des lois
libéralisant les marchés agricoles a
adopté en septembre par le gouvernement
maudit pour faire simple les
agriculteurs indiens peuvent désormais
vendre leurs produits à des acheteurs
privés sans passer par les bandits ces
marchés locaux réglementé ou l'état
garantit un prix de vente minimal des
denrées de base principalement le blé le
riz un désengagement de l'état mal
perçues par les agriculteurs
craignant d'être laissé à la merci des
grandes entreprises malgré plusieurs
tentatives de négociations entre
syndicats agricoles et le gouvernement
aucune solution n'a été trouvée
[Musique]
le message pour le premier ministre
c'est que ce n'est pas le gouvernement
indien ans c'est le gouvernement des
agriculteurs etc les agriculteurs qui
vont le gouverner nous ferons ce que
nous voulons vous ne pouvez pas forcer
vos lois sont les pauvres selon vos
propres caprice le 12 janvier dernier la
cour suprême indienne plus haute
juridiction du pays a suspendu
l'application des réformes agricoles
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
annonçant dans le même temps la
formation d'un comité d'experts pour
faciliter la médiation entre
agriculteurs et gouvernement ce dernier
a proposé un gel de la lisant neuf de
ses lois pour les 18 prochains mois
pas de quoi calmer la colère des
agriculteurs pour autant qu'ils exigent
leur abrogation pure et simple
c'est la fin de ces deux heures
d'émission mercier amélie béguin
cyrielle benavides bill polian david
voulzy louis et aux équipes techniques
de jean charles valentin on se retrouve
quant à nous dans quelques instants pour
un autre point complet sur l'information
à ce type sur arte france
[Musique]
alors que l'économie mondiale à plonger
les bourses elles tiennent le coup un
rebond forcément en mars après la chute
importante est tout à fait naturel mais
la hausse qui a poursuivi n'est
absolument pas en relation avec
l'économie aujourd'hui il faut tenir les
marchés à tout prix et pour les tenir
bien vous déversez des liquidités vous
avez une banque centrale qui fixe les
prix on est dans un régime de prix
administrés
on voit finalement bourse qui continue
de progresser malgré les mauvaises
nouvelles
il va maintenant falloir surtout
retrouver cette corrélation entre
l'économie et les marchés financiers
marchés financiers sont boostés boosté à
la dette boosté à l'argent qui est
imprimé par la banque centrale est la
principale conséquence c'est la
disparation de la valeur de la monnaie
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que des gants dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant une forme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire espace en direct puisque
on est on dirait qu'il ya quand même la
liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir 8e
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1964 ce qui ne
change pas c'est la condition humaine et
une certaine idée que la civilisation se
fait de la dignité